hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space it's okay go on to
the executive shuttle hall here alright
um I had a bit of problem with this save
I had to jump in now something about the
save file just didn't work but I got it
all sorted out so okay where are we whoa
hey hey alright looks like we got a
shuttle here lots of vents for ugly
monsters to pop out of I'm sure in here
oh I need help okay going in
ah here we go OOP afcars acquired what
the hell okay I don't know they're
pointing in the ship non-stop oh I am
going in the ship okay
when what the heck where am I going Oh
what was that I heard some I don't like
a monster
okay here well got it
that's why I need to get all those cards
all right now push the button
Oh No do you coming what that bum
where's your legs go
there he goes I should probably get out
of this group
um Paul I just got to hold them off
until doctor
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hold on big guy
I'll be right with you Oh engines of
course of course of course it makes so
much sense
come here come here bigger Kumu oh god
damn it stay there stay there for a
second I got it I got business to take
care of Oh
so watch watch this Oh Martin what that
another fast twitch again
what was that where'd you go what the
hell you just like ran off to the left
that was weird
okay whatever um talking clamps
oh hello dr. Guinan I'm coming my god
what what hey hey don't leave me you
dummy things wrong don't leave me come
on yeah I know that procedure what why
wait a minute Emily Nicole said to Isaac
is he just a hallucination is he just is
he actually real
I'll come on what if I'm supposed to
meet you somewhere why didn't you just
take me there why do I have to go to my
stupid head
meet me dad and we could load them all
on board yeah blows I meet him at the
flight deck okay you mean he may be real
but he's definitely crazy cray cray for
now okay all right whatever I don't even
trust you lady back the way I came
through the executive subtle the
executive sleeping your time mascot
oh hello buddy I need to be frightened
fine
many have gone before us yeah and now
it's time for us to take the voyage
together uh-huh oh yeah take its course
I'll give you the really guy really
you're that crazy so you just let for
those figures whoa hey him him oh man
that is hilarious if that was him he's
such an idiot ha ha ha that's it
wow I wanted it I wanted to kill him
myself I they just let that happen
oh all right
but the bodies are still huge a good
sign is whoa heard slop
you heard slop I heard tsunami which is
weird because normally whenever I come
to an area after I've already left it
everyone I'm not gonna get rid of the
contactor yeah I'm still gonna try to
keep it trotty
I don't think there's another level I'm
not sure level five sound like the max
one other than that I'm pretty good
maybe that should do it
- [ __ ] dude Lulu now let's go this way
I'm going back to the tram system
problem yep someone's still singing
twinkle twinkle little star hi who's in
here
good you knew what was good for you
chapter ten done haha by him completed
how many chapters are there now I don't
need to save chapter 11 alternate
solutions all right
oh I'm going back to the flight isn't
the flight deck where we came in
I think the flight deck is where this
all started
so okay all right come on bring it on
ready for all of y'all how reliable okay
now hello I'm approaching the shuttle
hangar that's how you must find your way
to the cargo bay
aha the balcony it's being stored in
there yeah that's there's a cargo
loading this there you can use to
deliver the marker up to the hangar
again great time to kill me and you just
go away bathroom I got to the Greek
here's some in the vents or something
I'm not exactly sure
okay
is it wait a min hang up is it this work
the tram repair room this is where I was
that's where the there that's why I
wasted ammo on the guy I am back hoes
did that oh hello guys how's it going
down there
no I paying off what is what is epic
alright nothing else here to be had
let's go on a merry way
be careful with stasis no you be careful
no you come on come on out I just want
to talk to you guys yeah probably not
someone made a mess of all that cargo
down there all right
um what was it why are those vents red
and why is that one completely bloody
that that does not make me feel safe
boxing
all right more contact energy blockers
all right not so good easy up the Marcus
broad can unleash hell
epic oh I'm ready for you Oh what that
I'm ready I got my fan
I'll handle that
Jesus module I got one of those who's
out there
hello I see you over there oh you all
some I forget if it is affected by
gravity or not not even coming through
the blood events the blood events
not today
whoa hello
five
by what
hi whoa that was weird
those baby monsters popped out of it
belly I thought he'd just popped out the
squid Lulu ah shut up guy
hey I get to test it up hold still for
me
another man this contact energy is very
powerful yeah
more
hi hey whoa hey Wow get off of me
get off me you so much contact energy
but that up boom hi baby
what's up boom oh you welcome to boom Oh
bigger boom I did it [ __ ] damn it
contact daddy
boom miss oh the old fire all fire
so all fire oh okay that just knock you
okay here we go boom oh come on how
tough are you let's get out here not
today
nah
Wow there we go Alison's death and
destruction has been handed out another
one
you want some to come back what's that
oh what's that in it
I guess I kind of have been reading and
missing a lot whatever done judge me
think I'm good to go or night
yep I am good to go yes away from here
our aim no accidents
good motto another one I'm just ignoring
you buddy
you're not I'm not the engineer unit all
right making progress
I love me some progress I started my
timer late so I don't exactly know how
long I've been going at it
whyever it's all good it's all good I'll
go a few more minutes just in case
I restored power to the elevator take it
over to the hangar bay and get the
marker on the shuttle okay I'm heading
up to the flight deck now okay I'm just
gonna run for it
yeah you don't need luck you so fine you
make it distract them all with your
looks
flashing as you run by that'll do it I'm
okay
I'll pick up more contact energy on the
way let's see actually uh all right I'm
just gonna cut it here because I don't
want to get into anything if I'm running
way over and I think I think I'm pretty
close so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye